today I'm talking about CVS but not any
CVS I'm talking about your CDs I'm
reviewing your CDs CDs that you sent me
before the session I reviewed them
thoroughly and I will give you my tips
and pointers on how you can improve them
if you're looking to apply for a
high-profile job such as a consulting
firm or investment bank where you come
to another coffee break with me my name
is hi Emily and this is my channel firm
learning where I try to help you to
become successful in the first years of
your career to start off your career
right you need to get the job in the
first place and a part of getting the
job is getting application material
right and this is specifically your
cover letter on your CV and today we are
going to especially focus on the
Seavey's of your application material
and to make this as hands-on as possible
now offered on my Instagram that you
could send me your CVS and then I would
review them and give you my tips here on
my youtube channel on how I would change
and edit them to improve them to make
them even stronger as always if you're
taking any value out of this video door
please hit the like button for the
YouTube algorithm and also subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on all my
content I'm releasing at least one video
every Saturday here on this YouTube
channel if you want to see even more
content from me also follow me on my
Instagram my handle is firm learning to
stay up to date and potentially also
participating in similar videos like
this by getting your material reviewed
in future videos this way today we are
going to proceed in the following way
first I'm giving you some general
remarks on how the structure of your CV
and my opinion should look like and then
I pick four CDs of the CDs that you sent
me
we will go in-depth into lots of detail
in DCPS and i'm going to make several
observations things that I observed what
you can do to improve them and I believe
these are really interesting and helpful
insights for all of you as well things
that you should all take care of things
that you should look out for when you
create your CDs and many of these are
things that I see frequently done wrong
but many people so hope and trust that
this is really going to be valuable and
interesting to all of you and to start
it off and it's important for me to say
that all the remarks and the things that
I will say and critique and give you as
a feedback these are my opinions I do
not claim that I know the truth about
how perfect
looks like there are many opinions on
that and maybe if you asked other people
they will give you another opinion but
hey you asked me this is my channel so
my opinion that's what you will get I
just always take it with a grain of salt
and in the end it's important that you
are comfortable with your application
material if you have a good reason for
deviate from what I'm telling you then
of course do so so let's go briefly into
some general remarks about the CV
structure one thing that I would
strongly recommend to you is to have a
one-page of format one page of CV is
just so much easier to read and
comprehend than a two pager CV
especially in anglo-saxon countries one
pager TVs are the standard they're the
norm and they're you really should apply
with one page of CV in some countries
such as Germany to pager CDs are
generally accepted as well and as a
general rule you should never go over to
pages and in general I highly encourage
you even in Germany to go for the one
pager it is always much better I love it
when I get a one pager CV on my desk in
my humble opinion it just looks much
more professional and it's much easier
for you to communicate yourself on the
one page of vomit and from the CVS that
you send me some are on a two pager
format and on these examples I will try
to give you some hints of what you can
cut down to get it down to one page
let's look into the content looks what
are the key content blocks that your CV
should consist of and in the structure
that I will propose here there are three
main content blocks and then two minor
content blocks in the footer I prepared
a very basic template of these different
content blocks that you have just as a
rough guideline at the very top you
should have your personal information
your contact information so state your
name your address your email your
telephone number and so on this will
make it easy for the company to contact
you without needing to look up other
application material of yours then the
three main content blocks are first a
professional experience second your
education and third your
extracurriculars your professional
experience this is where you list all
your jobs internships and similar things
in your education you list all the
degrees that you have the universities
that you attended in the
extracurriculars you especially list all
the social things that you did so any
kind of volunteering that you did
nonprofit organizations where you had
some
of leadership positions in and similar
things like that and you have honors in
what section where you can list all your
academic achievements prizes
scholarships beamless positions and
anything similar like that that will
make you stand out and in the end you
have an other qualification section
where you can list all your language
skills IT skills any other certificates
that you get and some of the things that
you might want to highlight to your
potential future employer so of course
this is just a rough structure more you
can debate how exactly the wording of
these headers from beep you can't debate
whether you should add an additional
line for hobbies at the very bottom but
generally speaking if you follow a
structure like that and your overall
structure should be fine and now when
reviewing the individual series I will
often refer back to the structure so I
have this in mind this is the basic
recommended structure that I will refer
to so without further ado let's jump
into it let's get practical and review
the first CD the first thing I'd like to
address is the one pager format so as
you can easily see the CV is on a two
pager format and I just want to address
the point that many of you are saying
when I just cannot fit this on one pager
but I'm telling you you can absolutely
fit such a CB on one pager format so
let's just go over a couple of things
this guy could do to get it on a one
pager the first is the header of the CD
with all the contact information you're
just so much space is wasted on a header
all the information here could just
easily be included in two lines or so
and we will see other CDs Envy sets of
four TV where this has been done so far
your header don't put each individual
item of information in one new line but
have them all in one line after each
other and this is absolutely fine Nexus
the borders at the sides he has a
significant margin to the left and to
the right if you would just take out a
bit of the margin he probably wouldn't
need some of the text breaks and some of
the bullet points so you would save a
whole line by doing that same is true
for the spacing between the dates and
the text there's just so much space
between the date and the text if you
would just let the text start a bit more
to the left you would save space and
probably save several lines in the
indentation before we now dive into the
content let's go over some other minor
format and layout things which I would
recommend
to improve so first garden 8 range
whenever you write something that is
still an ongoing activity the way he
puts it with the dash and the nothing
after that it's a career that would
probably not do it like this instead I
would just write since and then the date
without this empty - afterwards and the
font that he is using looks a bit
informal to me so I'm not exactly sure
which one that is probably something
similar to calibrate but at least for my
taste it looks a bit too playful and
Informers I probably go for another one
just a little minor thing on the bottom
right you see that he's the road
scientist so this is German for page so
of course if you have different versions
of your CVS in different languages
please make sure that you translate
every single word this is just a small
and I could see that of course should be
avoided now let's dive into the content
and let's start with the education
section what you see here that this
guide at some kind of a computer science
degree and probably especially if you're
fresh out of university with your degree
I'd also try to highlight your area of
specialization what are the focus fields
that you did during your studies and of
course if you apply for a specific job I
try to tailor it a bit that it really
fits the content of the job so for
instance if you apply for Finance
position try to tailor what you write in
your areas of specialization what's the
role I let the finance courses that you
did and regarding rates yes it's correct
you should always put your grades on the
CV - tips that I would have to maybe
improve the appearance of your grade is
the first whenever it makes sense for
you to name the person title of your
grade do it so here not this great 2.18
is of course on ok is great but if
you're studying in a very tough degree
subject maybe it's already in the top
10% or top 15% of performers of his
class with that great so I do not know
how in computer science the great
distribution looks like but if you can
make such a claim that you're in the top
10% of your class it's of course highly
beneficial then I would really recommend
you to add that to your grade section
another advice is with your feeders so
with your Bachelor feeders or master
feeders if you have achieved great and
your fevers that are significantly
better than the overall GPA of your
degree and I'm going to add the GPA of
the fever's as well and records after
the normal great regarding the exchange
semester that this guide that I believe
it takes far too much space especially
in comparison to the main degrees that
is actually doing so for the exchange
semester I put all of this only in one
line but this was safe online
we invested and going into more detail
on what you did in your main degree now
to the work experience section and here
I would encourage you to whenever
possible use parallelogram a structures
what this means is that from a grammar
point of view you start all your bullets
in the same way and you see this nicely
done it is Suzuki entry when it started
both of the bullets with the verb and
usually for the work experience section
it's good and advice to start with such
a verb because this not emphasizes more
on what you did what you actually did at
these positions and this is always what
you want if you have bullets which are
all written in the Parana grammar
structure it is much easier to stand
much more effortless to read the skills
on over a much more professional
appearance now the next thing on the
work experience in this might be the
most important point because this is a
feedback point that I will need to give
to every single TV in the bullet
describing your work experience you
should focus on the impact you should
focus on what you have achieved and not
only as a team but what your
contribution to a specific point was
what I mean by that is that you should
not just write a couple of general
passwords describing the activities on a
superficial level such as first level
support but you should rather say
exactly and specifically what you did
and what your impact was and whenever
possible also to quantify that so that's
a little exam and instead of writing
first level support you can write
something like responsible for first
level support of thousand employees
comma resolving 50 plus tickets every
day now this sounds much more like
impact if I read it as somebody who gets
the CV I can imagine much more what you
actually did then just by reading first
level support because this can mean
everything and nothing another example
you for the PwC position if you talk
about a roll out of a monitoring tool
try to get a bit more detail what
exactly did you do and how can you
quantify that so for instance say how
many users actually use your toilet so
if you can claim that you as a working
student created to that afterwards
hundreds of consultants use the PWC of
course that is extremely impressive to
add a bit more flavor or say specific
see what you did what if your
contribution was what the impact was
that you delivered and also make it
quantified this is really what steam
which is a strong framing of a work
experience from a weak one the next
point of observation that I have but I
also see other people doing wrong is
that you do not need to give equal
weight equal space and you'll see for
every single individual position so in
this specific example the position that
you had as a student assistant as a
Hester sure Lana's museum probably is a
bit less relevant it's a bit less
impressive for the most jobs that you
will apply to compared to for instance
your PwC position so I'd already give
more space in your CV to the things that
are really important and relevant and
less space to the things that are less
relevant and at some point if you've
collected now even more internships
maybe even already have a job at some
point you can also start dropping these
less important positions that you have
you do not need to list every single
internship that you did during your
studies just as an example also for me
on my CV even though I did all kinds of
internship during my university times
most of them I just do not list anymore
on my CV because now of course I like to
emphasis far more the actual full-time
work experience that I got after
graduating now regarding the
qualifications and skill sections the
first suggestion that I would have is to
put this behind below the volunteering
section so as I've shown you in my
overall template I believe it's common
practice to rather start with your extra
curricular us with your volunteering and
then start with the qualifications and
skills but now here if I look into the
qualifications and skills here I believe
there's lots of opportunities to cut
down space as well so for the languages
there's just no need to put languages
and individual lines you can just write
them in one line one language after each
other so languages and then German
English Russian French with the
proficiency level in brackets is
completely fine I will just take you one
line the next regarding software and
through it and I know many people do
that but from my perspective there's no
need at all to write about your
Microsoft Office skills if you are math
I graduate from a university people will
just assume that you have basic office
skills exception might be if you have
really in-depth knowledge or specific
fields for instance VBA then yes you can
put this for just writing about
Microsoft Office in general it's not
something I would do with just the waste
of space the very same is true for
Windows I mean come on people just
no expect you and trust you that you
will have basic knowledge of Windows
there's no need of writing that and here
there's a distinction between software
and the programming frankly here also
believe the desert of the waste of space
you can consolidate this much more so
for instance me I'm not an expert but at
least based on I know anaconda and
spider I des from Python it's completely
sufficient to just say that you're
proficient and Python there's no need
now to also mention or the IDE s that
you have worked with in the past maybe
this might be a bit more different if
you really apply for computer science
for a software developer position and
you know that these are the things that
are going to be used there but for
general business position there's no
need to go into this much of detail same
is true for our and our studio you will
need to mention that your profession and
our studio if you're proficient in our I
mean this is pretty much
self-explanatory so bottom line here
again from my perspective you can
consolidate the sole section in just one
line under the title of IT skills or
something like that and then just list
all of these things that you should be
completely now regarding the
volunteering section and here I would
focus much more on impact on your
leadership and focusing on mentioning as
many things as possible what people will
look for if they're rebe CVS is not that
you have been part of as many social
organizations as possible where maybe
you supported an event or did some minor
activities similar to the work
experience what you should really
highlight and focus on here's the impact
that you had its your leadership in such
an organization that will make you
really stand out so I'd say it's
completely okay to mention three
positions on extracurriculars I believe
it's also completely fine to only
mention to and focus much more on
mentioning the specific things that you
did and again quantify so if you
organize the conference say how many
people attended the conference if you
organize the fundraiser say what amount
of funds you raised if you're the head
of some kind of social organization say
how many people you are responsible for
how many members this organization has
this is what's impressive this is how
you show your leadership skills and
volunteering in the end should be about
the impact that you had right to make
sure that you mentioned this impact as
precisely as possible now to the
achievement section here again I believe
you can put this much more concisely
general I do not believe that it is
necessary to put the dates for
scholarships that you
nobody will care when exactly you had a
scholarship cause if you then submit all
the supporting documents with your
application you should also have
references for all your scholarships and
then these details will be listed there
of anybody's interested and generally
nobody will care about that so no need
to put the dates and instead of that
again I would just have one line with
your scholarships and then just list all
the scholarships that you have collected
this is really much more effective you
can save lots of space for that and
similar thing is true for the
publication's so and generally they have
a background in academia maybe you did a
PhD and have all kinds of applications
then what you can do is make an appendix
to your CV listing all the applications
so what you can do here instead of not
listing the full citation of your paper
it's again in the achievement section to
have one remark you just briefly mention
that you have a publication the XYZ
journal and then if the journal is very
rated if the journal has I'd say at
least a B rating or an A rating or
ideally of course and I plus rating the
rather say how the journal is rated
because this is what's really impressive
in the end it's not impressive to have a
journal publication and a completely
unknown journal that is of course
extremely impressive if you have an A+
publication so rather talk about this
than spending all the space on giving
the full citation of your journal paper
somebody is really interested in that
you can look it up anyways okay first
one done let's jump into the next CV and
I try not to not repeat myself too much
so I will not stress every single point
in the same way that now I already did
of course if you here see something that
I already gave you feedback on in the
earlier series the feedback will be
applicable here as well and this lady
provided me some questions that she
asked me on her CV so I will now go over
these questions and answer them and by
that I hope touched all the relevant
points here the first question is
whether she should keep the one-page or
CV because she feels like the city is
far too foil other than enough stuff
going on to spread it out in two pages
and by now I hope the answer is no
surprise to you that no you should keep
the one-page a form and this at least
would be my strong recommendation and
have no doubt at all that you can fit
all this information easily on a
one-page or CV because now the second
question was what I think about her and
lay out what you directly of course this
is a bit of an unorthodox layout this is
not a classical investment style one
page will she be able to see out there
my
general advice you would be to be
careful these kind of things so when of
course I wouldn't say that it looks bad
or something like that you should very
carefully look out for the types of jobs
that you apply for especially if you
apply for consulting or for Investment
Banking these companies are a bit
conservative and having such an
alternative design approach for your CV
will at least not help you in the
process so I'm pretty sure that nobody
in the HR department of Goldman Sachs or
BCG or wherever you say wow this layout
looks so great this is just not how it
works so best case people will be just
indifferent but of course worst case
would be the people actually irritated
by that no one could go through the head
of an HR person is that this candidate
potentially just didn't do her research
this candidate just doesn't know how a
CV should look like in such a
professional environment this of course
not the reaction that you want when you
apply to these firms so we might see
this a bit differently is if you apply
for a creative position if your platform
marketing agency or any other job where
creativity and open-mindedness is really
at the core of the job description so
for these kinds of positions yes I
believe it might be great idea to be a
bit more creative to think a bit more
out-of-the-box regarding the layout and
the style of your CV but of course this
is not a very specific fear that we are
looking at so my overall opinion on that
is that there isn't much of an upside of
using these kind of alternative cv
formats but there is the downside that
somebody significantly dislikes this and
believes it's unprofessional I would
just recommend not doing that and rather
going for a standard CV format you want
impressed by the content of your CV and
not by the layout another thing I
dislike about the layout that optically
the focus of this is here on the left
path there's the highlight I would claim
that this left section is rather the
stuff that you usually would put in the
footer of your CV so it's not actually
the stuff that is really at the core of
what the viewer should be interested in
but the most important stuff is rather
on the right so I do not think that
you're doing yourself a favor by setting
it up this way by highlighting the
things that are less important for the
viewer another thing that I'm noticing
at least if I see it correctly is that
the font size on the right smaller than
the font size on the left
and to me this just doesn't make sense
for the one reason again that the stuff
on the right is actually more important
than the stuff on the left but also I
believe that is in general bad practice
to use different font sizes in your CD
the only exception might be maybe the
name and the header which you maybe can
doing a bit of a higher font size but
even this is not necessary and for sure
within the audio of your study you
shouldn't work with different font sizes
this is just confusing to the eye and
another general remark for your date
ranges make sure that the orders of your
elements follows and logic and usually
you start by the things that are still
ongoing and you order the other elements
anti chronologically when they have been
completed or when this episode has been
finished but this is now not the case
here because if it is the case if the
things that are still ongoing output
first and why is this element that is
going on since November 16 there at the
bottom why isn't it about the TEDx
element if it's still ongoing so the
order of the elements here just doesn't
make sense to me make sure that your
lists to and some other questions and
this lady head is first what can I take
out and second what do I do with all
these online courses that I took so
let's start with these online courses
let's start with your education section
because I agree that the way this
education section is set up at the
moment is pretty confusing there are so
many elements in there and you really
need to pay close attention till you
really understand what your actual
degrees are what some other study
tivities were for instance these online
courses that you did apparently my
general advice here would be that I
wouldn't put online courses at the same
level as your full university degrees
rather have this footer section of your
CV this other qualification section and
there you can then list all your online
courses
you shouldn't have more than one line
for each online course that you took
this will save you significant space
here but it also will make it much
easier to read and much easier to
process what exactly you did what exact
your main educational background is
because of course at least today how HR
departments see that this is still your
university education and less some
online courses that you took and similar
thing holds true for this project study
from 16 so if I understand this
correctly this lady took some university
level courses while she was still in
high school
but this is of course pretty cool I'd
also not highlight this here in the
education section I'd probably rather
frame it for something to be
in an honors and awards section you can
frame it as an academic honor that even
though you were only in high school the
university already accepted you for a
university level course so I probably
write something like this admitted to
the XYZ project and then briefly
describing it afterwards by doing that
you can really save some space here in
the main section of your CV where you
should really highlight the main stages
of your academic career the next
question was how she should handle her
scholarship section what scholarships to
include and how to put it on the CV and
again if you follow my basic template
then you have the section honors and
awards and this is the section where you
can place all your scholarships you know
- what scholarship exactly you should
include something like the Fulbright of
course is a very prestigious and where
know what scholarship so yes it is for
sure or something that you should
include now something like the femme tag
so yeah I do not know what exactly this
is but it sounds good why not I mean
sure sure you can include this not one
thing where there are many questions
around is this FL o scholarships so this
is a scholarship that is pretty well
spread in Germany it's something that
quite a lot of people have but of course
not everybody has so people ask
themselves or should I include tiny
fellow scholarship or not my simple
answer would be that probably I would
include it if I have nothing better to
show so again looking at Germany once
you have collected the pmdf scholarships
something like student reform or
something like that and for sure I would
mention it anymore but if your section
on honors and awards still looks a bit
empty then yes sure why not then just
include it this is the one general point
that also said earlier what exactly you
include or not include on your CV
depends on what stage of your career
what stage also if your university study
program you already in the beginning if
you're fresh out of high school if you
are in the first semesters of your
university program it's completely okay
- or some group for instance internships
that you did during your high school
time which maybe were only a couple of
weeks long but over time once you did
more relevant internships more
prestigious internships and at some
point take this older stuff out in my
opinion you are strongly devaluing your
strong internships they stand next to
this high school thing you did for two
weeks somewhere where you were really
young person and same thing is true here
for the scholarships I would leave it in
until I have enough other academic
honors and awards and then at some point
and replace this if at all scholarship
now regarding the content how you
describe your work experience this is
really an area of the OCD I would highly
recommend you to go over that again now
I do not want to repeat all things I
said for the previous CV but it's really
important that you focus much more on
your contribution on the impact that you
had while working in these positions
again quantify always quantify try to
have a number and almost every single
bullet point that you use when
describing your work experience it's
similar thing actually is true for your
volunteering for your extracurricular
experiences where now to your
volunteering section here you list five
different activities most of them also
overlap somebody who reads the CV I
would probably doubt that you were
really able to have a significant impact
in all these positions so I would really
recommend you is to focus more maybe
instead of mentioning five things rather
cut it down to the three or so things
that you really feel like were the most
important most relevant to you here
again now focus on your leadership on
your impact what you did to really make
a contribution make an impact with your
community this is what your
extracurricular section should be all
about how you made a contribution for
the good of society now to the next CV
what I want to point out in the
beginning is that without from reading a
single word just from the look and feel
of that this is how a classical
anglo-saxon one-page recipe looks like
so if you wonder what a good and saw the
layout of an MVP consulting of an
investment banking city looks like this
is the look and feed that you want to go
for maybe some of you believe that it's
too food that is too packed with content
but what you need to understand is that
the feeling that you want to create the
look and feel needs to be that it's
completely packed with amazingness of
yourself this is the picture that you
want to portray so somebody who reads
the CV you want to just go over it and
read every single line and every single
line is just impressive great university
names great grades great accomplishments
great impact great numbers this is the
feeling that you want to go for what
you'll also see here is that in contrast
to all the other CVC has a very little
margins at the side at the top and at
the bottom again this is very typical
for these kinds of cities because this
really allows you to just stuff lots of
content into
this guy is currently an LSD master
student and he told me that he already
worked with the career services and is a
on a CV and you can really see that at
least for these high profile consulting
and banking jobs this is the style that
you should go for now the thing that I'd
also like to point out is how little
space he is using in the header to put
all his contact information if you look
at the other CDs there the contact
information take a quarter or even a
third of the page this is just a
complete waste of space you can just
have that in two lines or so in the
header and this is completely fine so
even though this is already looking
great I believe there are a couple of
things you can do to make this even
stronger one thing is that at least in
my opinion he did a bit too much on the
formatting so he uses capitalization he
uses bow it uses italic he uses
underlines individually this is okay but
I wouldn't do all these things at the
same time so probably for instance here
I wouldn't work also with italic font if
almost every single your CV is
highlighted by capitalization boldness
in telling underlines and so on this
user's meaning and these kind of
highlights you want to use to create a
structure on your CV so I promise just
take one step back and probably take out
for instance the italic font the next
thing is that even though as I said it's
great to really pack it with lots of
content you should make sure that it's
easy to understand when the new entry
starts here I believe that the distance
between two entries is almost the same
as the distance between two lines within
one entry so I would change that and I
would slightly increase the distance
between two entries to make it easier to
read when a new entry begins and yes
this is taking some space but in a few
moments I will also give you a bit more
suggestions on what you can do save some
more space so let's not jump into the
education section the first remark that
I want to make here is how you stayed
for n grades so this is now a CV in
English but he started in Germany and
it's kinda credit then what some people
do is in this example said they take
their German grade and then they try to
Paykel a bit into some other kind of
format and here in this example on to
the American format of 4.0 near the
general rule is that you should not
tamper with your grades you shouldn't
buy your own initiative not try to apply
some kind of calculation formula to
transfer it in any
and of other great system you should
always state the great exactly in the
way that it is stated in your diploma
that you received so of course now if
you did receive a diploma in English and
it showed the great and exactly this way
then it is fine but in general and would
not do these kind of calculations by
yourself same true is here for this
German school of Milan for the 9800
scale so of course if you receive the
diploma at the great estate in this way
then I would put it this way I wouldn't
do these kind of calculations by
yourself or just a minor remark on the
bullet with the police I program here
there seems to be a double spacing so
just take out one of the spaces
regarding this Brown University
pre-college program this is likely
something where you can save a bit more
space or probably not put this as
prominently here in your main education
section but for me this is rather
something you can put below under other
qualifications and the reason is that
even though Brown University of course
sounds great it's a great Ivy League
university you usually do not get
admitted to these kind of summer school
programs due to your academic merit but
usually you just pay for it and
everybody knows that right so I wouldn't
consider this not a great academic
achievement but rather put it below
under other qualifications where you can
just paint it in one line or so and
thereby save space regarding the content
here again I just want to encourage you
to focus much more on your contribution
on your impact just as an example in
your child care position you're right
that you develop teaching plans and that
you taught children yeah what you really
quantify this not for instance by saying
that you taught 200 humans in total or
by saying that you taught three
different classes of students or
anything like that this just makes it
much more tangible it really shows that
you made this impact that you were the
teacher really always tress much more on
your contribution the impact that you
had on the next point of fundraiser
point the guy asked me whether you
should include nor the quantification of
$1000 because he feels like maybe this
is a bit little of an amount to mention
that and at least in my opinion again
even though it's not the largest amount
and belief it's much more honest it's
much more tangible to write that you're
a thousand dollars then to not writing
that personally I believe that this is
the better
to do that this is the thing that is
just more powerful I got it hide me here
so why anything I notice that somehow a
part of the video was missing and all
the next section refers to a question
this guy asked me asked me two questions
specifically first called autumn is it
really to quantify all your achievements
and second is it okay to exaggerate in
your CV to what extent can maybe inflate
a bit the things that you did and what
is the line at issue of trust so now the
next section first
yes quantification is great it just
helps you to make the things that you
did sound much more tangible and really
helps you to tear out the impact that
you had in your role so to what level is
it okay to exaggerate and here I'd make
the remark that yes it's true that
probably most of the CDs that you get in
your hand there's some level of
exaggeration in it of course people try
to portray themselves as positively as
possible so because the competition is
doing you should of course not be shy
make sure that you restate all the
achievements in the appropriate level of
greatness do not hold back really make
it salient what the impact is that you
had the leadership is that you showed do
not be modest fear on your CV this is
not what will help you of course there
is a limit and this limit is where you
know making factually wrong statements
this for me is now an ethics issue while
I'm sure that many many people
exaggerate the things that they write on
their CV even beyond what's actually
factually true in my opinion this is
just unethical and I just would not
cross this line this will probably put
your the slide disadvantage compared to
some other candidates but hey I have a
son fair so now last but not least CV
number four this is now again a two-page
CV and here again I would of course
recommend you to put it on one page
especially because the second page is
barely used so here would be especially
easy for you to consolidate it all on
one page and this is something that
therefore would highly recommend next
thing you notice is that the header is
missing with the contact information so
as you we just took it out to anonymize
himself of course men and you actually
see be you should include a contact
information section at the top one thing
that I like about the CV is how I put
the dates
saying this because I now refer to this
earlier as well how is using these
numbers for the month than this legend
of the year
I believe this is a very clean and easy
to read and easy to understand format so
these for my taste this works quite well
regarding the overall layout be a bit
careful that everything is nicely
aligned so what you can see here is that
these blue lines they do not neatly
start at the very left of the letters
but a rather bit more to the right so
this looks a bit unclean this is just
not correct your line so just have a
look at that again please
the same is for the indentation so these
if I see this correctly and the left the
dates they do not all begin at the very
same plane to make sure that the
indentation is consistent and all the
bullets start at the same level so what
this guy did very well is the GMAT so
usually I would recommend to not put the
GMAT and off at the education section
that maybe below and the honours or
maybe in the other qualification section
somewhere below but of course if you did
a very strong GMAT as this gentleman did
maybe especially then if your other
grades aren't that strong and it is an
option that you could go for then also
include the GMAT next to the degree that
you took the GMAT for here of course the
demon of 740 is a very strong score that
my very very overcompensate some other
weaknesses in the GPAs of the other
degrees now because I already said so
much about how you should write your
bullets in your work experience section
let's rather look into the skills
section because here it is something
which I see many people do in some
variations which is personally I believe
you should not do this and this is this
real scale that he is using to measure
the level of his kids my first of all I
find it highly doubtful whether you
should include Microsoft Office skills
in general on your CV as also said
earlier but let's not assume that you
included well I would now be very very
careful is if you put yourself as a full
expert on such a topic you know 6 out of
6 points so basically a hundred percent
proficient user of this tool and just to
contrast that so I would consider myself
a pretty proficient user with for
instance exhales well but I would never
claim that I meant a hundred percent
right that I know it all about the tools
such as Excel because in Excel even
though you're already quite advanced
there are always more topics to learn
more topics to master let's start with
array formulas with power pivot with VBA
all these very advanced techniques
if you really master all these things if
you're really an expert then okay then
maybe at some point you can write that
just be careful here because as an
interviewer if I see this I would just
directly pick it up and challenge the
candidate a bit on that right and then
also the Microsoft Office suite is so
vast
besides these basic programs like
PowerPoint Excel or Word it also
includes programs like SharePoint or
access we really master all these
Twitter at the 100% level so guys be
careful and similar things are true for
your language skills so if you put
languages on your CV on the b1 level or
so and be ready that the interviewer may
be in the middle of the interview
switches to eat Elian or switches to
french just to test a bit where they do
have these basic language skills that
you claim to have so if you can't speak
these languages at this level this is
perfect but this is just something read
so really easy to call you out in an
interview so be careful the last thing I
want to draw your attention to here on
the activity section is hunting with
hunting it's a bit similar to an
affiliation to a political party so why
not trust that it can be a very
comforting leisure activity may be also
great conversation starter if your
interview partners interested in that or
maybe does the same activity it just are
people who see things like hunting very
critically some of them are not really
open for arguments but rather see these
things on an ideological evidence I
would probably not write on my CV that I
am a hunter cuz there might be some
people in HR believing that hunters are
really evil and unmoral persons why now
I trust it's easy to make an argument in
the exact other direction you just do
not want to put your application at risk
for such a stupid little thing okay so
let's wrap it up this was my review of
your CDs I hope that you found this
interesting and valuable and I hope that
you really took something all for your
individual CDs this way that this really
helped you get your application material
to the next level so now I'd love to
hear also for me you would if you have
other suggestions other tips for the
forcbs that we looked at leave a comment
below in the comment section so that
also the other people here in the
community can participate from your
knowledge I would HIGHLY appreciate that
and as always if you took any value out
of this video please hit the like button
for the youtube egg
them also subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on my content and please
also turn all the notification bellies
otherwise YouTube might not show you my
videos even if you already subscribed to
me if you want to see even more content
from me also follow me on my Instagram
my handle is firm learning thanks for
watching my name is Heinrich this is
from learning have a good day to all of
you